regarding the intentions still on the
intentions issue does one always have to
make intentions regarding when you're
about to fast and
secondly the timing of the intentions
can you just say something a little bit
about that as far as intention is
concerned as I mentioned earlier that
intention is a and our beloved Prophet
Mall said it's mentioned in book of
fasting Hadi number 2331 how beloved
Prophet said a person fast not accepted
if it does not make intention in the
previous night that means for all the F
fasting compulsory fasting making
intention the previous night is
compulsory it can be any part of the
previous night it can even be till as
late as just before the fa time any time
of the night you can make intention a
person can make an intention in the
beginning of Ramadan and it can be valid
for the full month of Ramadan unless he
breaks it if he sick or if he's
traveling then he has to again make an
intention but one intention is also
sufficient and many people think they
have a misconception that verbally
saying it allow is a must which is not a
requirement I don't have to say verbally
that I intend to fast because my
intention is a from the heart for
example if I get up late in the
night much before F time or
fasting suppose my
son when we have got up to do a
late in the night and my son asked me
that why have you got up I will tell him
because we have to fast it's already
understood the Nia is there I don't have
to say that I've got up too fast the Nia
is there so Nia is important near in the
heart you don't have to say it with your
tongue that's what most of the people
think and I don't know if any Hadith
which says that the prophet or the sahab
ever said loudly that I intend to fast
intention is in the heart and and one
intention is sufficient for the full
month of Ramadan unless as I said it's
broken but this is only for the F fast
for a voluntary fast fast which is not a
f fast intention is not a f because
there's Hadith again mentioned
in in the book of fasting Hadith number
2323 once the prophet he tells his wife
that I want food to eat and the wife
said that there's no food to eat so he
said okay I'm fasting that means his
intent
was not there before in the previous
night he made it on the spot he
abstained from Before Dawn but his
intention was afterwards in the morning
so for the voluntary fast it's not
compulsive to be made early the previous
except if it a very important voluntary
fast like the Ashura the 10th of muharam
Ashura or it can be the day of arat it's
preferable to make an intention before
because that's very important fast for
all the other voluntary fast
it's not compuls to be made before
previous night for the Nia there are
other three things which are very
important one thing if it's by force and
if something is broken then it can be
forgiven or by error or by forgetfulness
as Allah says in the Quran in Surah
chapter number 16 verse number 106 that
after a person has
believed then if he does something of
unbelief does something of kuf except by
force that mean if he does by force even
kuf or sh Allah will forgive so if
someone forces a person to break the
fast his n wasn't there he can be
forgiven and Allah says in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 286 that
oh Lord please do not catch us please do
not hold us responsible when we ear when
we make a mistake or when we forget so
if a person in his forgetfulness
brecks his fast like has water Allah
will forgive him or if because of a
mistake Allah will forgive him which we
shall deal later inshallah